Laura: YOU'RE GOING TO STEAL
MY THUNDER.
[LAUGHTER]
ALL RIGHT, WE WILL SEE YOU
TOMORROW.
I AM LAURA INGRAM AND THIS IS
"THE IGRAHAM ANGLE."
AND THE WEB THEY WEAVE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
SHOW, HERE ON "THE IGRAHAM
ANGLE."
WE LEARNED HOW PETTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND IS.
HE WOULD SEND AGENTS TO A HOME
OVER A DOCUMENT DISPUTE.
IT CAME MONTHS AFTER THE LEGAL
TEAM HAD VOLUNTARILY MET WITH
THE GOVERNMENT INVESTIGATORS AT
MAR-A-LAGO IN JUNE.
THE EXTENSIBLE REASON FOR THE
VISIT WAS THE CONCERN THAT
DOCUMENTS WERE RETAINED BY
DONALD TRUMP WHEN HE LEFT
OFFICE.
>> THE DOJ OFFICIAL SPENT SOME
TIME LOOKING THROUGH THE
MATERIAL.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS
COMMENTED THAT THEY DID NOT
BELIEVE THAT THE STORAGE UNIT OF
THESE STORAGE BOXES WERE KEPT
SECURED.
SO THEY OUT OF THE LOCK TO THE
FACILITY.
SO THEY BROKE THROUGH.
>> IF THIS IS THE BASIS THAT
GARLAND OPERATED ON, THAT HE
SHOULD RESIGN.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A SEARCH
WARRANT IN SEARCH OF A LEGAL
JUSTIFICATION.
AND THERE IS NOT JUST ONE AT
WORK HERE, IT TOOK A COLONY OF
RATS BURROWED INTO MAKE THIS
KIND OF ABUSE AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP STANDARD OPERATING
PROCEDURE.
JUST LIKE THE MICHAELY FLYNN
INTERVIEW AND JUST LIKE A
DISGRUNTLED ALEXANDER LINDEMAN,
DO YOU REMEMBER HIM?
AND NOW SUPPOSE IT CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AS WELL AND AGAIN, ON
BOGUS GROUNDS.
IT'S LIKE A BAD MOVIE BEING
PRODUCED.
AND NO ONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS AWARE THAT THIS WAS GOING TO
BE EXECUTED UNTIL IT WAS
REPORTED IN THE MEDIA?
>> A REMINDER THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS INSISTED AS WE HAVE BEEN
REPORTING THAT IT HAD NO PRIOR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE SEARCH IN
FLORIDA YESTERDAY.
>> NICE TRY, KIDS, GO BACK TO
ACTING SCHOOL.
OF COURSE THEY ARE GOING TO
CLAIM THAT THEY DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT, BUT THEY DIDN'T HAVE
TO KNOW ABOUT THE SEARCH AS IT
WAS HAPPENING, BECAUSE AS WAS
POINTED OUT LAST NIGHT IN A LEAK
LAST SPRING, THE WHITE HOUSE
SAID THE JOE BIDEN WAS UNHAPPY
WITH MERRICK GARLAND AND WANTED
HIM TO BE MORE AGGRESSIVE, LIKE
A PROSECUTOR, PROFESSOR OR
JUDGE.
HE IS NOT A DUMB GUY.
AND HE GOT THE MESSAGE.
AND HIS MARCHING ORDERS, YES, HE
GOT THOSE AS WELL.
IT WAS TIME TO PUNISH DONALD
TRUMP AND BY THE WAY, OTHERS AS
WELL ISSUE BEING A SECURITY
WARNING.
JUST AS THE ANGLE ANTICIPATED
LAST NIGHT THEY WOULD SEIZE UPON
CONSERVATIVE JUSTIFIABLE OUTRAGE
AS THE PREDICATE TO TAKING AWAY
MORE FREEDOM.
LISTENING CLOSELY TO THE
LANGUAGE HERE.
>> IT IS THEM SCREAMING BLOODIED
MURDER RIGHT HERE 3 THERE IS
FALLOUT FROM THE SEARCH ONLINE,
INCLUDING GROWING CONCERNS OVER
THE REACTION FROM POSSIBLE RIGHT
WING EXTREMISTS.
>> THESE FOLKS ARE OFTEN
INSPIRED TO PLAN VIOLENCE OR
CONDUCT VIOLENCE, SO I THINK
THAT THIS IS VIOLENT RHETORIC
2 I THINK VIOLENT RHETORIC IS
MORE LOUD THAN EVER.
>> BAD ACTING AND TERRIBLE
WRITING.
THE SAME DOJ THAT IS
RECLASSIFYING RUN-OF-THE-MILL
CRIMES AS DOMESTIC TERROR, AND
WANTING PARENTS TO OPPOSE
ATTENDING SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS,
AND THE SAME DOJ THAT NOW WANTS
TO CRIMINALIZE POLITICAL
OPPOSITION.
TO INTIMIDATE THEM SPEAKING OUT
OR ALIGNING THEMSELVES IN ANY
WAY WITH DONALD TRUMP OR IN
AMERICA FIRST AGENDA.
THIS IS THE ENTIRE POINT OF THIS
EXERCISE, IF THESE PEOPLE GET
THEIR WAY, CHINA WILL NOT HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT CENSORSHIP OF
AMERICAN VOICES, HEAVEN FORBID,
THE DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE ALREADY
DONE THEIR JOB FOR THEM AND ONE
THING THAT IS PATENTLY OBVIOUS
IS THE CURRENT REGIME IS CLEARLY
SURPRISED AT THE BACKLASH FOR
THIS POLITICAL STUNT INCLUDING
CRITICISM FROM NUMEROUS
HIGH-PROFILE REPUBLICANS LIKE
MARCO RUBIO THAT I JUST
MENTIONED AND MIKE PENCE AS
WELL, AND THE REGIME MEDIA IS
ESSENTIALLY REDUCED TO ASKING
EVERYONE TO TRUST THE PROCESS
AND SEE HOW IT PLAYS OUT.
BECAUSE HE WOULD NEVER DO
ANYTHING UNTOWARD.
THEY DON'T EVEN BOTHER DOING
RUDIMENTARY REPORTING ANYMORE.
THEY REDUCE TO ASKING EVERYONE
TO TRUST THE PROCESS TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
THEY ARE SO DESPERATE TO TRASH
DONALD TRUMP THAT THEY GO TO THE
GUY THAT THEY HAVE TRASHED FOR
YEARS.
>> TODAY I RECEIVED ABOUT TWO
DOZEN COMMENTS.
I THINK EVERYONE SHOULD ALLOW
THE PROCESS TO GO FORWARD AND
INCLUDING SOME INFORMATION FROM
VLADIMIR PUTIN OR SOME PHOTOS OF
MISSUS TRUMP.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE A CASTING CALL
REJECT.
AND THEY MADE A MISCALCULATION
HERE.
THE ORGANIZATION IS GOING TO BE
USED IN THE SAME ABUSIVE AND
CORRUPT MANNER AS THE FBI AND
THE DOJ.
THIS IS A POWERFUL POWERFUL
ARGUMENT THAT THEY HANDED TO
EVERY REPUBLICAN RUNNING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY IN HOUSE OR SENATE.
AND IT TOOK THE FOCUS OFF OF THE
NEW SPENDING BILL EMPHASIZING
THAT THE DEMOCRATS CARE MORE
ABOUT HURTING POLITICAL
OPPONENTS THAN ACTUALLY FIXING
THE ECONOMY AND THE DAMAGE THAT
THE JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
GONE TO OUR GOVERNMENT.
INCLUDING THE PENTAGON, THE CIA,
THE DHS, MUCH OF THE CIVIL
SERVICE, I THINK IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO CALCULATE AT THIS
TIME, BUT IT SEEMS LIKELY THAT
MANY OF THESE AGENCIES WILL